Kevin joins us now Paulie just mentioned
that he had no sympathy for cole hamels
because he's too good-looking to have
sympathy for is that fair yeah whatever
senator fairies rich also so Polly
throwing the salary and the looks and
the height and he's probably wonderful
in the shower so all that you're right
the sympathy you don't feel it well you
always talk about best and worst bodies
and yeah you've played with a few of
those guys what about better bodies
because you talked about Schilling had a
bad body right yeah yeah Schilling
Schilling did not look it was not easy
on the eyes and a shower down we've
talked about many times in the show as
far as good bodies gabe kapler is a
wonderful body in the shower there's now
the the head of the Dodgers minor-league
farm system so he was a wonderful man in
the shower let me go down team a team
how about that we'll start with the
Florida Marlins back in the day Derrek
Lee six foot five gorgeous man in the
shower first baseman high ceiling 21
year old we trade with kevin brown I was
the Crash Davis that played behind him
we'll move on the Boston Red Sox we went
with Gabe Kapler will stay there
Baltimore Orioles tough one here but I'm
have to go with Jay Gibbons and Brian
Roberts both of those young men had the
obliques Jacobs with the big arms Brian
Roberts stopped growing when he was in
fifth grade but good-looking young man
the shower Toronto Blue Jays this is a
tough one I also say something I've
popped my head Scotty rolling you know a
young man out of a Bloomington Indiana i
would say country store yeah country
stroke Country Strong ran Tommy a man
ski type home run trot around the bases
arm no showboating was sorta but he was
he was very strong and very nice quads
you know he had like The Trevor Hoffman
quads in the shower now these are all
the team's you played for right but that
would be it yes four of them you like
released by the Cubs but we can go the
Cubs I me if you want to go to Custer
retrying did shower were six weeks where
the guys are the Cubs and I would have
to move a see Aramis Ramirez no Derek
Lee was on a team will go with somebody
else other than Derek let me then we
just means take a quick jaunt around
Ryan Dempster is not too shabby for a
Canadian kid that took a ferry to play
catch back in the day and got dry
two sec around the Texas Ranger saw goes
ryan dempster who is once again nice
quads no well there you go all right
Kevin well thanks for joining us that's
all we wanted to talk about hey real
quick Danny how are you honest to god if
you and I were teammates and I was doing
a radio show about Dan Patrick in the
shower are you average below average or
above-average I've been called a
five-tool player really yeah okay so you
go on the record saying you're above
average then yeah they call me the Swiss
Army knife I didn't have a toolbox that
was me all right what do you make of the
results yesterday with Toronto rolling
all over Texas what does that mean and
the Indians with their fourth starter
beating the Red Sox number one starter
yeah let's start with the Blue Jays and
Rangers boys they come out this is the
one sport i will tell you you get
penalized when you are the number one
seed because this is a sport about every
single day we go out there its timing
that's defensively turning double plays
that's offensively hitting obviously 95
minor of fast balls you can take as much
batting practice as you want the Rangers
had a five day layoff for Friday layoffs
and you saw a team lebleu Jays they've
been just playing baseball they've been
playing baseball the Rangers were a tick
off and you can even say more than a
tick off both sides of the ball
offensively and defensively the Blue
Jays came in there and boat race them
that's that so I don't know how you cure
that because every it just seems like
the the seeds in football you can heal
you want the time off and basketball you
can heal in baseball it just doesn't
look like they come out hot and fresh
and tight so they got beat up pretty
good Red Sox Indians listen I mean first
inning poor cell looked wonderful Bauer
looked like he was going to give up
three to four runs got out of it was
only given up one with a great tag you
know at home plate and then you saw
Porcello get the ball up and the Indians
went knick-knack patty-whack I think
that was a big game for the Indians win
because now you have Corey Kluber and
now it's about all the songs because
price one in 2012 in Coober one in 2014
you're going to look at a good game at
both of them at 228 strikeouts in 220
seven strikeouts so you can look at a
game with some strikeouts the only with
kubarz we don't know about that quad I'm
he has a pitch to the you know since the
end of what September sometimes so it'll
be interesting to see how he feels how
long he can go because Francona can't do
the same mix that he'd last night no the
gutsy move last night with Andrew Miller
in the fifth inning we're talking to
Kevin Malhar for the major league
baseball Network we tossed around this
topic after Madison Bumgarner had that
great outing if you could have Clayton
Kershaw's career right now or Madison
Bumgarner's well I'll take Clayton
Kershaw's financials immediately so I
know the future financials of Madison
Bumgarner are going to look awesome you
know it's always a great question
Madison's got the Rings you play this
game to win world series championships
because you're up you're going to make
money and mass is making money in this
game so right now you're taking mad
bombs career should the Cubs be the
favorites well yeah but they've won the
most games are most talked about team
but once again they could run in the
same exact trap as the Rangers they've
been kind of sitting back haven't played
a meaningful game I mean they've been up
15 games it seems like in the central
since since all-star breaks so this
could be a very similar situation if
they're not careful because you're
facing Johnny Cueto you're facing good
pitching in this postseason you know and
this is what happens and you might see a
very similar situation but yes they're
the favorites on paper yeah but I think
only two of the last 27 teams that won
100 games went to the World Series why
is that that's not a coincidence yeah
IIIi can't you're right I can't answer
that question other than the reason why
you would say that they're the favorites
because Jon Lester's last ten home
starts he's 90 and he finished up strong
he's thrown the ball as well as anybody
they got to saw young type candidates
hendrickson Lester for this season one
of those two guys going to win it in the
National League can we make sure to the
other guy that deserves it but you're
looking at just a moxie of the starting
staff for that Cubs rotation with John
Lackey two World Series rings Lester's
obviously got rings there you're looking
at Jake Arrieta last year this guy still
good we've kind of forgotten about him a
year ago last year we're like he was a
great pitcher on earth yeah so he's your
three starter that's why there's a favor
they still have young at-bats and that
lineup you know Dan and we'll see what
happens more important to therefore in
choices we had this topic Big Papi or
Derek Jeter man that is such an awesome
question i'm going to say Big Papi
because not just because I did shower
with him for many years but I'm going to
tell you he's one of the true and only
rock stars we have in all of sports left
you know conor mcgregor's trying to
become a rock star on his UFC stuff you
look at Big Papi and I've said this
before he can roll in in a pink
lamborghini countach with both doors
open papi and diamonds on the license
plate a million and a half dollars worth
of jewelry and this big smile and he
thinks he's a rapper cuz he's watching
you know MTV that night and you go wow
that's papi if dan Patrick did that I'd
be like wow dude you know so it's just
one of the few guys I'm telling you
Danny that that is just he's able to be
this icon and Derek Jeter one number to
jog down to shortstop and you're at
Yankee Stadium you know you're in
trouble but he's like Santa Claus you
never saw him you know he's back door
VIP under the tunnel down the set down
the chimney Papi's coming in the front
door and I think that's what separates
those two it's always great to talk to
you Kevin Danny you do great work buddy
I'm always watching you I admire your
body of work Kevin all right you're
above average of below average we got
that on thank you kev it's a Kevin mala
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience